le coup pauline marois était très ému
cet après midi lorsqu'elle a pris la
parole pour la dernière fois à titre de
première ministre sortante et là tout
d'abord fait le bilan de son
gouvernement elle a aussi rencontré le
premier ministre et lui fait des
couilles en or pour assurer la
transition
retour donc sur une journée est chargée
en émotions martin biron le dernier tour
de piste de pauline marois le moment et
crève coeur alors qu'elle tente de
cacher sa peine et de faire ses adieux
il y aura bientôt sept ans que que je
suis sorti de mon jardin
la douleur est vive pour elle et pour
ses collaborateurs très émue et je ne
regrette rien a dit pauline marois et
j'ai le sentiment du devoir accompli
je suis encore ému que les citoyens du
québec mais permis d'être leur première
ministre elle est fière de ce qu'elle a
accompli pour les familles surtout elle
a évité les analyses de sa défaite tout
en affirmant que la souveraineté reste
nécessaire je laisse un parti en bonne
santé et je suis fier de l'avoir dirigé
pendant autant d'années
merci
entre temps les déchiqueteuses sont à
l'oeuvre autour du parlement alors que
la transition du gouvernement marois
vers celui de couillard est en cours ce
matin le premier ministre et lui a fait
sa première visée dans les bureaux qu'il
occupera bientôt pauline marois l'a
acclamé par absolument certain que nous
nous entendrons le tête à tête a été
particulièrement court environ une
dizaine de minutes
quand il est ressorti fait les couilles
arts a qualifié la rencontre de cordiale
normal ça fait un dernier conseil des
ministres a suivi l'occasion pour son
équipe de rendre hommage à pauline
marois mais aussi pour certains de
penser à l'avenir
donc moi je pense que des grandes crises
peuvent sortir des grandes choses faut
pas se mettre la tête dans le sable
c'est évident que on a du travail à
faire entre nous après ça c'est de
préparer l'avenir de préparer la
reconquête de la population ce qui reste
regarde en avant et s'engage dans la
reconstruction de leur parti pour
pauline marois elle restera à la tête du
pq jusqu'au 7 juin
discrètement ici martin biron radio
canada québec